all right major developments tonight in
the massive FISA abuse scandal we'll
start there now we are getting one step
closer to holding top-level Obama FBI
DOJ deep state officials accountable for
what is a severe constitutional abuse
now they completely have shredded the
Fourth Amendment rights of the American
people and people could and should end
up behind bars now the Attorney General
jeff Sessions thankfully is now saying
tonight the Department of Justice will
be investigating these FISA abuses let's
watch we believe the Department of
Justice must adhere to the high
standards in the FISA Court and yes it
will be investigated and I think that's
just the appropriate thing the Inspector
General well I take that as one of the
matters you'll deal with finally we have
been unpeeling this story for over a
year well of course the liberal media
they've been lying to you obsessing over
so-called Trump Russia collusion which
is nothing more to this point that a
conspiracy theory that they have created
out of thin air there's no evidence and
by the way as for the extensive
unprecedented Obama era FISA abuses we
now have a mountain of incontrovertible
and corroborated facts and evidence
liberal congressman Adam shifts his
counter memo on PI's abuses has actually
confirmed everything that we have been
reporting on and everything that is also
in the two Republican memos on the
scandal that's why the mainstream media
has completely been ignoring what is
inside the shift memo
it doesn't fit their narrative and more
importantly it doesn't damage President
Trump which of course is their ultimate
goal here's everything that the shift
memo corroborates from the Nunez and
Grassley gram memos this completely
unverified Clinton bought and paid for
dossier that use Russian government
sources made up in fact a large part of
that FISA application to surveil Trump
campaign associate Carter page Adam
Schiff actually writes that a section of
the FISA application references parts of
the pony dossier about Carter page
meeting with Russians in Moscow in June
of 2016
page by the way is denying these lies
and that they'd never
proven true I think Muller would have
arrested him by now
or at least charged him now remember the
Grassley and Graham memo said that the
Russian dossier made up the bulk of this
FISA application now shift didn't say
that but yeah he admits the dossier was
used and the shift memo also
corroborates that in fact the FBI and
the DOJ lied and purposely and
maliciously misled a FISA judge about
Clinton and the DNC paying over 12
million dollars for the Russian dossier
of unverified lies in propaganda can you
believe this is happening in our country
now shifts memo actually quotes a part
of the FISA application about the
dossier having political motivations but
here's the thing the application never
bothered to mention that it was Hillary
or the DNC that paid for that dossier
the FBI knew this but they purposely hid
it from the FISA judge not rank-and-file
FBI that higher echelon that we talked
about they used it to get a warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign
here's another key point that the ship
memo confirms that the FISA application
yeah they did mention a yahoo news
article by Michael Isikoff that he wrote
about quarter-page ship however lied
about the fact that the judge was never
made aware that the source for the Yahoo
article was Christopher steel now the
Republican memos they actually detailed
how this is a major problem because that
means that the information was never
verified by two independent sources
since Steele was the only source so
those are points that the ship memo
actually confirms and here are the key
facts that the shift' memo flat-out lies
about the congressman claims that the
Trump campaign was never spied on that
is a lie a hundred percent false and
here's why when the federal government
granted a FISA warrant that gives them
access to every one of Carter pages old
emails old text messages and they know
every phone call he made which could
date back to when he was with the Trump
campaign now shifts at former deputy FBI
director Andrew McCain that he never
testified that without the dossier they
never would have been a FISA warrant
application but the shift memo never
offers any proof which
likely means it doesn't exist and my
sources confirm that in fact McCain said
that and Schiff does admit that steel
was fired by the FBI for these media
leaks but what ship doesn't say is that
steel lied to the FBI about his media
contacts and the ship memo tries to play
up Christopher Steele's credibility by
saying well he's worked with the FBI in
the past yeah they just fired him here's
the problem
Schiff never mentions that steel was
using Russian government sources and
that the information was never verified
independently by the FBI or the DOJ or
by anybody so it should never have been
used for any FISA warrant application at
all and finally Shipp omits this
critical piece of evidence according to
our reporting the dossier put the FISA
application over the top in other words
we've been telling you that the first
time they tried to failed the FISA
application was denied but then the
dossier
well they added that to get the help
that was needed so they could quote get
it approved and then they lied to the
judge and what it all means is now we
have three congressional memos that
prove a key fact the FBI lied to a FISA
judge about Clinton in the DNC financing
the dossier which was filled with
uncorroborated Russian lies and they did
it to spy on the Trump campaign the
Attorney General jeff Sessions glad he's
moving he needs to move quickly
everybody involved needs to be held
accountable we need to restore the rule
of law all right also breaking tonight
we have more news about Broward County
in the Sheriff's Department missing
countless warning signs about the
Florida School shooter and then utterly
failing to properly respond to this
deadly rampage now this is one huge
massive giant bureaucratic failure after
another in this case and Broward County
sheriff's got Israel
well he's flat-out refusing to take any
responsibility instead he's blaming
pretty much everybody else
according to reports this is almost
unconscionable for of Sheriff Israel's
deputies did not enter the building
while the school shooting was happening
one deputy a school resource officer on
the scene his name is Scott Peterson he
was armed with a gun and a bulletproof
vest he took up a position out
the building while the shooting was
taking place one student described
Peterson as standing still as he heard
shot after shot being fired
no Peterson's defending his actions and
ended up resigning and what we're now
learning is that the first member of law
enforcement to enter the school they
were actually from the Coral Springs
Police Department those officers rushed
right in Broward County deputies they
took up a defensive posture in position
outside and also new tonight Fox News
reporting the Broward County Sheriff's
Department also prevented the EMTs from
entering the school and there are
questions about well you know would it
be proper protocol students and teachers
were shot and dying and bleeding now
sources are telling our own Laura
Ingraham that Broward County Sheriff
deputies they were told not to go into
the school unless their body cameras
were turned on even though those
deputies apparently didn't even have
them and Sarah Carter breaking news
tonight reporting that under sheriff
Scott Israel leadership apparently
they've been at least 40 investigations
into that department and misconduct we
did reach out to the sheriff's office
for comment on Sarah's story we haven't
heard back this is all one huge massive
giant blunder after another while
students and teachers were being
slaughtered inside the school and sadly
that's just part of the story we know
the FBI was alerted not once but twice
about Nicholas Cruz and his sinister
intentions including weeks before the
massacre one unidentified woman told
authorities that she feared Cruz would
quote get into a school and just shoot
the place up the Naples Daily News
reported that Broward County Sheriff's
Office received a teen specific warning
calls about Nicholas Cruz since 2008 and
law enforcement imagine this visited
this kid's home a whopping 39 times in a
seven year period and we also know Cruz
raised all kinds of red flags at school
he wasn't allowed to wear a backpack
because of security concerns and it was
ultimately expelled because of his
behavior and of course he posted all
these disturbing images on social media
warning signs missed at every single
level here now people did the right
thing they saw something they said
something
alerted authorities these authorities
dropped the ball on a level I can't even
comprehend they didn't do their jobs
they failed this community in Florida
and these officials need to be owning up
to their mistakes so it never happens
again and we can fix the problems in the
system prevent a future massacres but
that's not the case you've heard people
like Broward County Sheriff Scott Israel
he's refusing to own up to his failures
he won't answer key questions he Pat's
himself on the back and as a general
overall lack of sympathy
watch this when did you find out
the deputy Peterson had not gone into
the building how soon after the shooting
did you know that not four days we how
many investigators looked at I'm not
sure one week after the shooting you
hadn't looked at the video yet I looked
at the video as soon as our
investigators uh it wasn't my job to
look at the video was investigators job
to look at the video the families were
at the CNN town hall and you could have
disclosed it's not that's not
we didn't I couldn't disclose it then
because there was no corroboration shake
I could only take responsibility for
what I knew about ie exercises my due
diligence
I've given amazing leadership to this
agency leaders fully resigned it was
ashamed of course I won't resign do you
think that if the Broward Sheriff's
Office had done things differently this
shooting might not have happened listen
if ifs and buts were candy and nuts you
know
Oh J Simpson would still be in a record
book obviously the sheriff is in denial
out of touch with reality it is why
people are now calling on him to resign
instead of doing everything that we just
showed you sheriff Israel he should be
apologizing to the victims families and
correcting the issues that didn't stop
this mass shooting and his deputies
going into that building
sheriff Israel doesn't appear to be
interested in doing any of this in fact
last week he said that he might not even
release the footage showing deputy Scott
Peterson failing to enter the building
listen to what he says we're not going
to
disclose the video at this time and we
may never disclose the video depending
on the prosecution and the criminal case
but what I saw was a deputy arrived at
the west side of building 12 take up a
position and he never went in
unbelievable whatever footage the
sheriff has it should be released to the
public the American people all of you
and the people of Florida and these
families deserve to see it if they want
to see it
sheriff Israel needs to stop trying to
save his job focus on protecting this
community that he's supposed to be
serving